Muy buenas tardes pues aquí estamos en
la Plaza de la ópera es desde aquí desde
donde debe partir esta manifestación
Dentro de pocos instantes y que
terminará en la Plaza de la bastilla en
cuanto a participación se espera que sea
menos masiva de lo que hemos visto en
ocasiones anteriores especialmente a
finales del mes de febrero y a finales
de el mes de enero este es digamos un
poco digamos la dinámica que se ha
venido presentando en las últimas
manifestaciones las autoridades creen
que hoy de estas doscientas
manifestaciones alrededor del país
deberían contar cerca de unas 400.000 a
600.000 personas en toda Francia aquí
como ven pues ha habido bastante lluvia
un poco de tormenta en París pero igual
la gente continúa llegando aquí para
realizar todo este recorrido pero
también debo decirles que en la sede de
él Este es el gigante del lujo en
Francia pues hubo unos 400 manifestantes
que llegaron a esta sede muy cerca de
los campos elíseos e fueron allí en ese
edificio personas que trabajan en en la
empresa ferroviaria del país así como
trabajadores del sector de la salud y
del sector de la educación eso por ahora
lo que hemos visto y lo que se ha
presentado aquí y también muchísima
muchísima presencia de la policía
alrededor de este lugar desde donde
partirá este esta manifestación el día
de hoy y Natalia mañana se espera la
decisión de la corte se han convocado
también en marchas para este viernes y
qué reacciones penan las autoridades de
este movimiento de protesta en caso de
un fallo a favor del gobierno
así es Pues por ahora no hay
manifestaciones pero sí estarían tal vez
convocando a la gente para que se reúna
en la plaza que hay frente a la alcaldía
principal aquí de la capital todo esto
va a depender también de las
autorizaciones que de la prefectura de
la ciudad no hay manifestaciones
previstas pero sí las autoridades están
muy alerta teniendo que en algún momento
pueden comenzar detonar algunas
manifestaciones de pronto un poco
violentas en algunos puntos de la ciudad
Lo cierto es que todo el digamos la zona
alrededor del Consejo constitucional que
en realidad no está muy lejos desde aquí
donde nos encontramos está más digamos
sobre esta Avenida un poco que está
tapada acá por todos los manifestantes
pero está hacia abajo sobre hace unos
500 metros pues allí estará el ahí está
el consejo constitucional que ya está
pues lleno de policía alrededor de esta
sede en cuando como usted lo preguntaba
si es la segunda decisión tiene que ver
con ese referendo Pero esto va a tomar
bastante tiempo Rodrigo porque para este
referendo en la realidad se necesita que
un quinto de los parlamentarios voten a
favor Es decir unos 185 entre diputados
y senadores pero sobre todo se necesitan
4,8 millones de firmas de electores
franceses que voten a favor de este
proyecto un proyecto que ya ha sido
presentado ante esta consejo
constitucional por parte de la izquierda
francesa los de la nubes que es la
coalición de izquierda en todo caso los
sindicatos han dicho que están
dispuestos a encontrar ese 10% de firmas
que representan esos cuatro punto ocho
millones Casi cinco millones de firmas
de los electores y que están seguros
Además de que van a poder obtenerlos
pero estamos hablando un proceso largo
que bien puede demorarse prácticamente
un año antes de que este este digamos
este texto de esta reforma pensional
pues pueda ser sometida a voto popular